what i'm talking about more is all of
the institutions of society the
non-governmental institutions of society
in large part becoming more and more
intolerant of dissent outlawing dissent
social ostracization
people losing their jobs people having
family members not speaking to them
anymore
and and this is leading to a complete
breakdown in the possibility of us even
having
a republic together it's really really
dangerous stuff and everybody feels it
this is the part that's amazing
is that we're all being gaslit by the
media that says that this stuff is not
important
or that you know it's just making the
country better but by polling data
every single subgroup in the united
states including mainstream liberals
with the with the exception of far-left
radicals with the exception of the far
left
every single subgroup in the united
states says they are afraid to say what
they believe about politics publicly
that's insane okay that is a good
indicator of where we are and
how far we have to go
you'll be proud to know ben as a refugee
of los angeles
that you know we have this mask mandate
in effect again and i went to a
restaurant this weekend i went to home
depot this weekend and i went to a mall
this weekend
and i did not wear a mask and guess what
an awful lot of people nodded at me
you know in support a lot of people uh
were not wearing masks and yes when i
went into bloomingdale's and they asked
me to put the mask on
i did because i'm not trying to you know
get somebody fired or get into a fight
with somebody
but i bring it up because enough people
are sort of like
okay it is time to move on and that's
just where we're at at the moment
yeah well again i moved to florida and i
will tell you this if they try this
whole
vaccinated need to mask up again
nobody's doing it and people weren't
doing it
originally here i i can't imagine that
people are going to do it here and again
yeah the governor understands has been
very big on everybody should get the
vaccine if you are if you are physically
able to get the vaccine
and there's not much more than that that
he can do and i'm i'm just
i'm do i got to say just on a data level
i'm bewildered by this i was looking at
the seven-day running average of death
from covid
the average number of deaths from covet
according to the new york times seven
day rolling average right now
is 269 and when we're at the height of
the pandemic it was well over 3
000 people a day who were dying so we
brought down that factor by a factor of
10
and we are now seeing fewer people die
every day in the united states from
covet than die
on a normal day from diabetes right and
269
269 i mean are they giving us ages on
that or other health you know the
co-morbidity stuff because that's that's
a very small number of course we don't
want people to die
but it's a small number well i mean
again if you're going to talk about
public health crises
then you really do have to talk about
the number of people who are dying and
the number of people who are being
hospitalized and the fact that the media
will do things like play with stats
where they'll say well you know we've
had a
40 increase in the number of
hospitalized from three weeks ago and
it's like
yes but the number of hospitalized three
weeks ago was very very low
like a 40 increase means we are still
very very low so
this doesn't mean that we're making
light of any of this sort of stuff what
it does mean is that
statistically speaking the people who
are getting serious breakthrough
infections have significant underlying
illnesses
very significant underlying illnesses
and the people who are mostly
getting hospitalized and and the people
who are who are dying tend to be
people who are unvaccinated and that
really resides in sort of the middle
section of the age range of the
population because
dirty little secret pretty much
everybody who's over the age of 65 in
this country got the vaccine
yeah ben i'm not a mathemagician like
you are but if there's one person who
had covet and then the next week there's
two what's the percent increase on that
that's a 100 increase right my god
that's a huge
huge increase all right well all of this
leads us perfectly to the authoritarian
moment because it does
seem like we are in it right now um
are you sort of having a pat yourself on
the back moment because i've been
feeling
that a little bit lately like we were in
a group of people
that were screaming about all of this
about five years ago not to say there
weren't plenty of people doing it before
that
but like we were really on the internet
like front end of like guys this
horrible thing is here
and everyone kept saying no no it's just
on college campuses and now it has
burst forth for everyone to see yeah no
question i mean
you know i used to think as a religious
jew there's a whole take on prophecy
that
the prophecy is like god speaking
through you but i i tend to think now
that prophecy is more along my monadian
lines
just seeing very clearly what's
happening right now
i think the reason that orwell's 1984 is
prophetic is not because it was prophecy
it's because he was actually describing
a thing that was happening in the soviet
union at the time
and so when we look at things happening
elsewhere like wow how could he foresee
he wasn't for saying anything he was
literally describing
and describing what's going on you know
five years ago
and then looking what's happening just
it was a smaller phenomenon then it's a
much larger phenomenon now
and i don't think any of us were profits
i think that we just all saw clearly
what was happening
and the direction that people were
moving and the authoritarianism that i
talk about in the book is really not
the government top-down authoritarianism
that we've worried about in the past the
idea the government is going to tell you
what to do although that may be the
natural outgrowth
of a sort of attitudinal
authoritarianism that's taken over what
i'm talking about more is all of the
institutions of society the
non-governmental institutions of society
in large part becoming more and more
intolerant of dissent outlawing dissent
social ostracization
people losing their jobs people having
family members not speaking to them
anymore
and and this is leading to a complete
breakdown in the possibility of us even
having
a republic together it's really really
dangerous stuff and everybody feels it
this is the part that's amazing
is that we're all being gassed by the
media that says that this stuff is not
important
or that you know it's just making the
country better but by pulling data every
single subgroup in the united states
including mainstream liberals
with the with the exception of far-left
radicals with the exception of the far
left
every single subgroup in the united
states says they are afraid to say what
they believe about politics publicly
that's insane okay that is a good
indicator of where we are and
and how far we have to go what do you
make of the
the last liberals at this point i mean
do you
consider them part of a new conservative
movement or some sort of wide tent thing
on the right i mean that's what i would
say i'm not talking about obviously the
crazy lefties
but the last few the the sam harris is
the barry weisses whoever else is left
like what do you what do you make of
that crew at this point i mean so
frankly i think that the
the future of the country rests on them
because i think that the folks in the
middle are going to have to make a
decision there are a lot of sort of
mainstream establishment liberals who
have a decision to make the decision is
this
they can either move along with the
hardcore left with whom they agree on
policy a lot of the time
and they can get their left-wing utopia
at the expense of individual rights
comedy having a country or they can say
to the radical left look we may agree
with you on a lot of your policy
prescriptions but the way you're going
about this is going to break the country
and we need to have these discussions
with people on the right we need to
preserve individual rights and if it
takes us longer to get where we're going
or maybe
even if we don't get there at all the
higher principles are still worth
standing up for
i am unsure of which way the
establishment liberals are going to go
because you do see things like the
harper's letter with 150
you know liberal intellectuals saying
that they they are very much in favor of
individual rights it would have been
nice to see one trump supporter on that
list
it would also be nice to know really
whether mainstream establishment
liberals are interested in opening the
overton window
wider than themselves in other words are
they saying we don't like cancel culture
for us
or are saying we don't or are they
saying we don't like cancel culture even
for people with whom we disagree so
today on twitter
i put out sort of a challenge uh maybe
called the nice bucket challenge but
the the the basic challenge is if you
are a person in politics
can you name and publicly say about
somebody who voted differently than you
that they're a nice person
can you say that because the answer for
a lot of folks on the left is no
the answer for a lot of and i'm
including mainstream liberals there
people who just
will not treat you as a human being
publicly they won't come out and say
publicly
i disagree with this person on nearly
everything they're a nice person and
you should read their stuff and consider
it you say that kind of crap all the
time i say that all the time
i literally refer people to left-wing
podcasts and say you should listen to
them and listen to me and then decide
who you agree with i've never heard of a
left-wing podcast that has suggested
anything remotely similar about my own
ben because you're a nazi right duh
right i mean that's always worked
yeah i i hate to tell you that i think i
can give you the conclusion on your
hypothesis here which is that they're
not
they're not for the most part going to
move in the direction you want them to
move i don't think they'll necessarily
move towards the left anymore
but they'll stay in this sort of
irrelevant limbo phase
because i i've met and i you know i know
a lot of these people and they
just more than anything else more than
saving the country they just don't want
to be called conservatives because you
guys are very scary
you guys are very very scary it's a real
problem and it's why
i open the book by talking about january
6th because i think that
there's a trick that's being played
right now and it it's why the democrats
are trying to do the january 6th
commission make a big deal out of
january 6 listen
january 6th was a big deal but it was a
big deal because law enforcement
failed to stop a couple of hundred
idiots from running into the capitol
building the notion that it was a
full-scale assault on democracy that was
going to end with the overthrow of our
democracy
the worst democratic situation since the
civil war in the words of manchester
united
wait a minute wait a minute aoc said
that we were an hour away from uh
armed insurrection or we were an hour
away from martial law is which yeah it's
insane i mean
it's totally and utterly insane the what
i what i pose at the beginning of the
book is a basic question
who let me give you two realities okay
one is we have january 6th it's an act
of evil by a bunch of idiots who are
going to be arrested and go to jail
then we have an entire left wing that
labels the entire right-wing responsible
for january 6 starts suggesting overt
social controls with regard to
media with regard to free speech starts
de-platforming places like parlor using
neutral service providers like amazon
web services
starts openly moving to push social
media
to ban people like mainstream
conservative voices
starts talking to corporations about how
they're not allowed to give any more to
members of the republican party who
didn't vote the way they wanted them to
vote
on certification of the election without
actually overthrowing the election right
which one is more authoritarian a bunch
of idiots running into the capital
building and then getting themselves
arrested
or every major institution in america
declaring january 6th such an
unbelievable crisis that they have to
maximize their power over your life i
mean it seems to me that there's a wild
imbalance in the amount of institutional
support
from one authoritarian ideal versus the
other if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click
the notification bell